good afternoon everyone uh today uh we
have Mr D P so uh we'll have a and he'll
be talking more on how to become a
successful dech YouTuber to give a
background of Mr D Patel he was with
Bloomberg as a data engineer and uh
currently he's he's a full-time YouTuber
making a lot of content on data so it's
our privilege to have him at the St
today uh so without further Ado uh I'll
welcome Mr Dil and and uh for we look
forward for this session so thank
you thanks for the kind introduction uh
it's 3:20 so I promise I'm not going to
show you any scary looking technical
architecture diagrams or C snippers uh
the talk is going to be really light uh
so I a full-time YouTuber I run this
channel called code Basics where I teach
data science machine learning data
analytics uh things like that before
going full-time on YouTube I I was
working at Bloomberg as a data
engineer and I made close to I think
more than $300,000 a year uh but my
channel grew to a level
where I started making this number so
obviously it was a no-brainer to quit my
9 to6
job all right now that I have caught
your attention let me show you the
reality this is the picture of my
YouTube Studio it shows my monthly
earning barely pays my
mortgage so the question is why did I
leave the
job not only me there are many other
folks for example Kevin worked in
Microsoft as a product manager for 14
years he quit his job and he is a
full-time YouTuber
now then we have Zach Wilson who was a
data engineer at adbn
I think he was making when he quit he
was making like $600,000 year
he's into a LinkedIn influencer he's a
LinkedIn influencer uh he has a YouTube
channel but his his main PL platform is
LinkedIn uh not only individual
contributors but you see people like
anur waru who is a CEO and a founder of
a company he's also a full-time YouTuber
now so once again the question is why
how does YouTube manage to recruit the
top talent in the world so you guys have
any idea if the YouTube ad revenue is
penut why would people do this fulltime
why would they go for YouTube as a
full-time career any
guesses you build the large audience
okay you build the large audience and
then monetize on me then monetize yes
that's a great answer once you have
large following
monetization becomes really
easy um and in order to understand the
answer of this question we all will
probably agree with one statement which
is YouTube has become an omnipresent
University right you want to fix uh your
car or you want to teach your kid uh
math anything you just go to YouTube and
you will find a good quality content
since we are in a data science and
python conference I'm going to talk a
little bit about how YouTube has democr
democratized data Science
Education this is the picture of Village
I grew in uh on the left hand side you
see my home I lived in this home until I
was 22 23 I was going to the college uh
when I was living in this home here you
see my school where I did my where I
took my primary education
and back in those days the source of
knowledge was pretty much the local
schools and
universities we had very limited access
to books actually we did not have any
libraries nothing you had to travel far
away in a nearby City and there too you
get just limited amount of books but
today if a kid is growing up in the same
exit
Village they have access to this right
Mr Andrew Angie can be teaching them
machine learning uh
lectures in countries like India and
many other developing countries like
Nigeria Bangladesh and so on the
internet infrastructure has improved so
I'm seeing this trend where people don't
have laptop but they have phone and they
can get good internet uh in countries
like India for example the internet is
very very cheap I spend few months in
India every year and the price I pay for
my internet like my phone phone internet
is I think it's like3 or $4 a month okay
so people have access to super high
quality internet at a very very cheaper
rate and that enables them uh to get
education from these awesome resources
which are available on the internet
Stanford is not the only Channel you see
a lot of other channels from individual
creators who are producing exceptional
quality content one of them is three
blue one brown how many of you know
about this person see you you might have
seen his videos this guy is amazing if
you have not seen any of his videos I
would suggest you go watch his video on
neural network I think it has
accumulated some 14 million views and he
uses this visual techniques he has built
this software by the way on his own okay
he he buil this visualizer software on
his own and he uses that software to
explain complex
topics so three blue one brown is one of
such creators you will find many other
uh creators through through whom you can
get a good quality educational
content and this has resulted into
transforming many lives I'm going to
mention few stories mahad Jam was a
mechanical engineer uh and when he
finished his
btech he thought mechanical engineering
doesn't have much scope so he decided to
learn machine learning he learned
everything from YouTube he did not pay
for any courses he did not take any boot
camp no univ nothing he was able to
crack machine learning uh job interview
to today is working as a senior deep
learning engineer in one of the product
companies then you have Ed G who is a
data scientist from
Nigeria he also learned pretty much
everything from YouTube when I was
talking with him on LinkedIn this is
what he said right YouTube played a
better role than any school for me so uh
some of us might have a perception that
YouTube is more like uh an additional m
material that you can reference to but
that is not the case there are many
folks who are learning who are using
YouTube as their kind of main source of
education and they are getting jobs and
they are being being successful in the
industry so YouTube offers obviously
some of the benefits which is there's a
best quantity best quality content
available for free uh it is a self-based
learning so you can rewind you can go
forward something you can't do it in a
classroom Style
teaching and you get community
interaction too say you're watching a
video on grade in descent on on any
channel and if you have a question you
would think uh where do I go and ask if
I'm in a classroom I can ask my teacher
but you'll be uh glad to know that many
of the YouTubers they have built this
private Discord and telegram communities
for example my own Community has 38,000
people and if you ask any question the
community Is Amazing by the way and you
will get an answer in a very reasonable
uh time frame so there is definitely uh
an interaction element so now let's go
back to the original
question so YouTube ad
earning is often a very small portion uh
when you think about the income stream
for any YouTuber okay they earn money
through for sales affiliate earning
sponsorship and so
on Zack Wilson for example he posted on
LinkedIn I think few weeks back that
he's doing a data engineering boot camp
right now and these are some of the
other revenue streams that he's having
and he's making close to $120,000 a
month and his startup he left his Airbnb
job just 7 months back so it is pretty
substantial uh once you have a good
following and once you are delivering uh
like good educational content in form of
boot camps or paid
courses in my case too I have this
platform called code basics. where I
have a bunch of courses and boot camps
and the company has generated more than
half a million in past one year so you
definitely get Financial Freedom uh when
you choose YouTube as a career and when
when when you're able to grow there the
reason I'm using fin uh the term
Financial Freedom is it is passive
income you make your videos okay you
make your courses and these courses are
valid for n number of years so while you
are at sleep your courses and your
videos will continue to make money for
you so you get uh Financial Freedom but
for many YouTubers uh see initially of
course Everyone likes money but that
money element will attract you in the
initial phase but then there are other
factors which will which you will enjoy
a lot being a YouTuber for me personally
it was purpose and impact so until 34 I
was working in the teag industry I was
working with Bloomberg prior to that I
was with Nvidia I was very happy with my
career and when I started posting videos
on YouTube I came to a realization that
teaching is something I love if I didn't
do that experiment I would have never
known that teaching is my thing so
YouTube experiment help me find out my
iy you might have seen this diagram
before iigi is this sweet intersection
of what you love what you're skillful at
and what the world is ready to pay you
for once you find that and if you build
a career around that you will grow not
only financially but you will grow uh
holistically uh in terms of your overall
happiness of your
life so for me personally what happened
is I started teaching I started loving
it and I found that I have some skills
in that area and with YouTube it's very
good that the community the crowd is is
very blunt you know they will just
comment if you're not speaking things in
a certain way for example I'm not a
native English speaker so sometimes when
I pronounce certain words uh I don't
pronounce it them properly and my
audience will just bluntly tell me that
at 3 3 minute 2 seconds you did not say
this right and you can use that feedback
mechanism to improve yourself um and
then you get this kind of messages uh on
everyday basis where people are getting
jobs let's say a student is in
University it is your videos are helping
them clear their exams uh and it gives
you this deep sense of satisfaction uh
which is kind of hard to describe I also
travel to various parts of the world and
conduct a lot of community meetups um
majority of my students are in India so
I go to India every year spend spend few
months there uh and I just love that
experience of meeting and interacting uh
with different
people the other benefit of a YouTube uh
career is time Freedom we talked about
uh videos being passive right you're
producing a video your audience will
watch the video at their own convenience
and you don't have to work based on a
fixed schedule so what happens is that
you move away from work life balance to
work life
Harmony the work doesn't happen based on
a fixed time schedule it happens based
on the state of your mind so let's say
on a random Wednesday if I don't feel
like working I can take off you know I
can go out for a walk or sh Shing or
whatever and on Saturday at 2:00 in the
afternoon if I have a burst of Creative
Energy I can go and record my videos the
YouTube career gives you that kind of
flexibility there is of course a
location Freedom you can work from
anywhere so these are some of the
benefits of becoming a
YouTuber now let's see how one can
become a successful YouTuber like how
can you start today so YouTube of course
has become a very competitive um place
right now uh but I will I will give you
some framework based on my own
Journey so 7 years back I did some
research and I figured out the most
exclusive and unique content and I
published a video on that
okay and the reason I did this video was
not I didn't know anything about YouTube
I I didn't know about monetization
nothing there are 20 other channels
teaching python okay so this was not a
unique by the way it it was like very
obvious but my reason of starting a
YouTube channel was very different so I
was diagnosed with an autoimmune
condition called ulcerative colitis it
is also known as um irritable bowel
disease and my doctors told me that it
is not curable I was bleeding day in day
out I lost so much weight I was on
medical leave for months and living on
uh fruit
juices at that time I was aware that my
health is a total mess but those few
months I realized one more thing that
more than my physical health I think my
mental health was getting impacted badly
because when you are free working like
sitting at home what do you do you do
Google right okay Google CTIC colitis
what is the cure complication and you
know what happen happens like whenever
you're doing Google related to any
health topic you get into a depression
state so that's exactly what was
happening with me and I said I need to
spend my some time where I'm not
thinking about my freaking disease okay
I wanted to spend time in doing some
activity where my brain is totally
engaged I can take myself out of that
for Loop and just be engaged into some
activity which I love and which can help
someone
so I thought all right I know python
I've been working as a python programmer
for so many years why don't I make
python tutorials there's something I can
do it from do from home and it will kind
of fit well um in terms of the situation
I was going through so I started posting
videos one by one and after few months I
started getting some comments all right
your videos are LIF Savers I'm like oh
my God my existence is worth I'm not
this poor guy lying on my bed and you
know waiting for some hope that
something will happen to my heal of
course people exaggerate a lot on
YouTube but you realize that you have
some skill or something that you can
contribute back to the world so I kept
on posting videos after one year of
consistently posting video I had 1,000
subscribers so if somebody is starting
today with a goal of becoming this
famous YouTuber or with a goal of
earning a lot of money that person would
quit because for one year making those
videos is lot of work and thousand
subscribers is nothing but in my case I
was very happy because I had zero
expectation my mental therapy was
already working I was improving my
mental health right the whole purpose
was to disengage my brain from that
health research for
and I achieved success on that this you
this count was meant nothing for me
because I had no plan of going full-time
in YouTube I thought okay I'll keep on
posting my video while I'm happy with my
Bloomberg job so then I started
experimenting previously you would see
if you look at my old videos you would
see only a wide screen where someone is
typing the code and that's it it's
pretty boring but later on I started
incorporating my face in it so this is
one thing about YouTube people love to
connect to another human being so if you
are showing your face if you're
narrating your story they would they
will engage better and I started putting
all these presentations then road map
videos I myself interviewed for many
years at Bloomberg and Nvidia so
obviously I started sharing some
interview interview preparation tips and
simple explanation was something uh
which I was good at so I started posting
videos on topics like convolutional
neural
network as a result the channel started
growing and as you can see while in 2016
after one year of hard work it
accumulated only th000 subscriber I get
that many subscriber in like a day or
two right
now so what contributed to my own
Channel's growth so I'll highlight those
points and I'll will then talk about a
generic framework that anyone can use uh
to start a YouTube channel and grow it
so in my case I knew that my main
strength is simple explanation
convolutional neural network is for a
beginner it's hard to understand I knew
how to break that concept down into
smaller chunks and then connect the dots
so I knew that strength and I kept on
focusing I focused on that strength and
kept on making videos one by one and
sometimes you know you don't know what
kind of skills you have it is the
YouTube crowd the people who will help
you uh recognize that you have this
talent I didn't know that um I'm good in
explaining things in a simple way but it
is through those YouTube comments that I
kept on receiving again and again then
you realize okay this is a validation
okay Market the people are telling that
this is the area where you really Excel
and then you just do that you just focus
on that you obviously get feedback and
improve right so reading YouTube
comments so in my initial years nowadays
it I get so many comments it's kind of
hard to read but in the initial few
years I would read each and every
comment and respond to each and every
comment can you experiment and diversify
slowly how I diversify it from plane
coding tutorials to interview prep and
road maps and all of that you just do it
slowly and patience and consistency is
the most important thing so YouTube
algorithm will reward you if you are
consistent let's say you are posting on
a weekly schedule or let's say two times
a week or whatever that schedule is but
you need to be posting
consistently So based on my own Journey
I'm going to lay out five steps
framework for anyone to become a
YouTuber so the first step is going to
be find your Niche and find your
audience okay there
are variety of things that you can make
videos on you can make videos on Rust
programming or python or just career
tips you need to figure out what is that
area where you you like producing
content on and and there is a demand for
that so YouTube provides this nice
research tool so if I'm going to show
you a demo of yoube studio uh in few
minutes but in here when I search for
llm Project it will tell me that llm
project has a high demand so there are
so many people looking for llm project
term and not only that it will also tell
you if there is a Content Gap content
Gap means there is a some search some
term which people are searching for many
times but they're not finding a good
content on it
so if you find anything which which has
a Content Gap you make a video it is
likely that it will become a
hit and then you can find an
intersection of content language and
style so content means you can use
YouTube research tool to figure out um
what type of topic you want to build
content on and then you can if you find
that there are other YouTubers
successful YouTubers producing videos on
that that topic don't worry you can
maybe produce similar videos in a
different language now you would think
okay who will watch machine learning
videos in Hindi and I had that
understanding that you need to produce
videos in English right on topics like
machine learning and whatnot but
actually I was wrong there there is a
huge demand of content in the local
languages for example since I'm not a
native English speaker if I if I'm
searching for a video and if I see two
videos one is in Hindi one is in English
I'll probably watch it in Hindi because
I feel little relaxed while I'm watching
that video because it's my native
language um and then you can use style
so there are people like jch how many of
you have seen jch video right he his
main main thing is humor so he he was I
think working as a data scientist but
now he produces Totally T humor content
and then there are some people who teach
well using analogy and they on their
there are other folks who have lot of
Industry experience so whatever content
they produce you you will see that
industry experience get reflected uh
into their content so you can find uh
this kind of intersection where you feel
that you'll be able to deliver value at
the same time you will enjoy doing that
process and that that comes to the next
point which is once you have figured out
that this is the area where I want to
focus and build videos you can now use
your St strength and post high quality
content consistently so consistency is
very very important if you have when
you're starting out and if you have some
goals that okay in 6 month I want to
reach 50,000 I think it's it's likely
that you will give up because it will
not work the way you expect it to work
you need to fall in love with the
process okay so get attached to a
process not the
outcome step number three will be
experimenting engaging and then feedback
and improve okay so that's the process I
talked about when I want to post videos
or start a new tutorial playlist I will
conduct a survey on my channel and kind
of get a feel from of the demand that
people are having I also ask okay at
what time you guys watch my videos and
based on the PO result I will uh adjust
my scheduling
all right so let me now give you a demo
of my YouTube
studio so anyone can start a YouTube
channel by the way you can all you need
is a Google account and uh once you have
once you have started your channel you
will uh get access to this particular
thing called YouTube studio so here I
can see all my content right I can I
think sharing need to extend oh yes
sure
sorry okay so
here here uh I will see all the videos
which I have posted uh and then you you
see the likes and kind of likes and
dislike kind of ratio for example for
this video for 97 likes I got three
dislikes so if you can consistently uh
rank above 90% which means overall
people are loving your
content then you can short it by views
so let's see if I want to see like which
of my videos had the highest views so
this is how you see it and then there is
this analytics
tab which shows you the the subscriber
growth your revenues things like
that so let me
just okay so this shows like see I get
on average on average I think 55,000
views every day then in terms of
subscribers see there are days where I
get like this is like on October 30th I
got 585 new subscribers on my channel
and this this is a revenue
okay and the
views you can go to see more to see
which videos are performing best let's
say in last 28 days I want to know which
of my videos perform better so these are
those videos and you can just look at
their daily views per video you can also
go here and look at your
subscribers so for example data science
road map video on November 1 got me 53
new
subscribers
okay presume a project Challenge on my
portal sorry about
that need to go
back now let's go to the audience tab so
in the audience tab uh let's
see okay
sorry asking me to verify
something just a
second what a perfect
timing
yes
yeah use the yes but no but it's my
pixel
yeah your
[Music]
phone so internally I
get oh no
okay thank
you yeah so in terms of your audience uh
you will know when they're watching most
of your videos so you'll get this kind
of heat map where I know that between 10
10 a.m. on Saturday to 12:00 p.m. on
Saturday my audience is active so I can
then schedule my videos during that
time uh it also shows you the
demographics obiously you can see here
uh the age
group uh then it shows you obviously
your Revenue graph your monthly
Revenue uh your top earning content for
example
here so let's see
here and this is the research tool that
I was talking about right so if I see
let's say llm project which was like a
Content Gap I think few weeks back but
now now it's not see so the this topic
is still in a high demand but there's no
content Gap because probably some people
would have posted
videos so let's say you if you want to
start a channel maybe you can start
posting videos on llm project because
that's one of the high demand
topic all right so that's research tool
Revenue content and just in case if
you're
curious
yeah here here you can turn on and off
your monetization and YouTube will
decide when exactly uh it wants to play
the
ads so let's move back to the
presentation
now yeah by the way any questions so far
uh we can keep this
Interactive
I have few more like Steps okay but yeah
we can any questions on a YouTube Studio
or generally any questions so
far okay so uh let's go back to step um
the the five step framework so we were
at step three and the step number four
is Outsource so let's say once you start
a channel and once it has started
growing you can uh start outsouring
Outsourcing some of the activities on up
platform like upor you you can get
pretty good uh freelancer and they can
help you with not only with U video
editing they can help you with thumbnail
design SEO and things like that and step
number five is obviously you need to
build a community so Discord is uh one
platform that many people use telegram
channels slack channels and this is a
way you can uh keep your community
engaged and then what people do is they
also become active on other social media
platform for example I'm more active on
LinkedIn you will see some influencers
being active on Tik Tok or Instagram uh
so you can do that as well all right so
that's a quick summary of the fstep
framework in case if you want to start a
YouTube channel and grow
there so that's it folks uh that that
was my presentation uh any
questions if you will start over again
um would you choose a different platform
Tik Tok
or I would I would still uh Choose You
YouTube because YouTube is better
because I'm a tech YouTuber for
technology YouTube is better because you
can post long form content like
tutorials and things like that there are
there are people who are in technology
and successful on Tik Tok as well but
see that you can get see having
subscribers is one thing and
monetization is different thing if if
you want to do this for your living uh
you need to make sure that the there's a
term called Revenue per subscriber so
for example there is a there is some guy
who is making fun videos right they may
have like 5 million followers but then
if you look at their revenue per
subscriber it will be pretty low and on
the other hand let's say some gu is
making uh videos on you know like
executive leadership
they may have maybe 10,000 subscriber
but their revenue per subscriber will be
very very high cuz then they can have
very high ticket courses which they can
sell so definitely like if you're in a
tag space uh YouTube I think is still a
good platform uh to become active
on community
part yeah for building the community
part first of all really thank you
appreciate the sharing and it's very I
really appreciate your
transparency and then like curious about
the community building uh like do you
have any like best practices to share
and also like some M steps to share yeah
so uh in terms of best
practices so this you can choose either
Discord or telegram or some platforms
which are easy to use and if you look at
Discord it has this gamification aspect
to it so people love interacting via
that platform and once you have started
let's say your Discord Channel Discord
server you can appoint some you can set
up some processes to appoint Community
Champions cuz like I can't manage such a
big group so I have I have gotten some
volunteers you know how how we are doing
P like all these people are helping uh
with the event organization you need to
do something similar and kind of reward
those people
uh who is helping you keep your
community vibrant so that is what I do
like I periodically look at uh the
contribution from different members then
I will have interaction with them or
you'll try to reward them in certain way
so that they also feel
inspired yeah so that's yeah the steps
and the steps the steps like something
you love CH something you would love to
avoid is yeah you need to keep uh some
control because we see that lot of
people who are into sales and marketing
you know who want to sell their for
example in my case I get all these
people who wants to sell their courses
and sometimes you see lot of spam coming
in so you you want to have some
regulation rules and regulation some
control over what kind of what kind of
content people post on it and that is
something that you can evolve over a
period of
time the interest of time I think we can
have one last question
um my question is about uh short form
content like do you have like any of
those and then how do you go about
making those I recently so I did not
have much of the short form content but
I recently started posting YouTube
shorts because some of my team is asking
me okay I need to do
that uh so I'm what I'm doing is I
already have long form videos so I will
just create short form content out of
that so let's say if I'm saying okay
learn data science in this five steps
five or six steps I will make a I will
have a long form video where I have
talked about details in those steps but
then I'll make a short video where I
would just quickly summarize and then
say if you want to get access to a
detail video uh check the link for for
the long form
video well uh I think we're good uh I
just have one last question from my side
like U having followed your content from
a long long time uh like since it's a
non-conventional uh know any kind of
thing what YouTube Bringers so how did
your family react and like know being
it's not easy to for any family to you
know make an assumption that this would
be a main source of Revenue like how did
your family react and how did you
convince them I think more than my
family my my friends or my wife's
friends they were more concerned about
this then me my wife was very supportive
but my wife's friend they like oh what
the hell he's doing you need to stop
him uh I think it's uh since I was doing
this for a long time four five years uh
I my wife was kind of very supportive
and she knew that I have a lot of
passion you need to convince them that
there is something you are doing for
your passion and working in TCH industry
for a long period of time I think your
kind of money hunger gets satisfied at
some point right it's not like once you
are out of college you have college debt
and all that you work in the industry
for some time you earned enough money
and now it's everyone kind of
understands that okay it's we have
savings so when I quit my job I made
sure I have savings for next one year
and after one year let's say if this
doesn't work out I can always go back
and and work again so that was my whole
Theory and I explained it and and my
family was like in support with that
decision
well that was amazing
Mr thank you so much